pour contrer la volonté d'annexion des
territoires Ukrainiens l'Ukraine veut
agir rapidement volody myrs edenski doit
présider ce vendredi une réunion
d'urgence du Conseil national de
sécurité et de défense réunion au cours
de laquelle des décisions fondamentales
devraient être pris selon Pierre
la Russie n'obtiendra aucun nouveau
territoire ukrainien la Russie va
sanexer à la catastrophe qu'elle a
entraîné dans les territoires
occupés de notre pays
de son côté la communauté internationale
condamne fermement la Russie le
secrétaire général de l'ONU dénonce le
comportement russe qui n'a pas de place
dans le monde moderne elle est décédée
de décision russe de poursuivre en ce
sens mettra encore un peu plus en danger
les perspectives de paix cela prolongera
les impacts dramatiques sur l'économie
mondiale en particulier sur les pays en
développement et entravera nos capacités
à livrer de l'aide d'urgence à l'Ukraine
et au-delà et les grands temps pour la
Russie de faire marche arrière
alors que Moscou s'apprête à entériner
les référendums qui se sont tenus dans 4
régions ukrainiennes les condamnations
pleuvent Paris dénoncent une provocation
supplémentaire de la part de Moscou le
Royaume-Uni ou encore les États-Unis
refusent de reconnaître la légitimité
des scrutin
je veux être très clair à ce sujet les
États-Unis ne reconnaîtront jamais
jamais les revendications de la Russie
sur le territoire souverain de l'Ukraine
ce soi-disant référendum est une parodie
une absolue parodie dont les résultats
ont été fabriqués par Moscou les
États-Unis et leurs alliés cherchent une
réponse proportionnelle à faire contre
la Russie de nouvelles sanctions
pourraient rapidement voir le jour